So, back to talking about praying of the
saints because I think that that's what
I'm going to bring up.
>> Uh I heard someone I heard a a priest I
I want to be respectful because one I
don't understand the tradition, you
know, because I wasn't taught that. Uh
so,
>> you want me to cut you off here? Here's
my point.
>> Go ahead.
>> It's because he trusts me and he loves
me. He thinks I'm the best teacher
because he agrees with my
interpretation. See what I'm saying? But
I can show you 10,000 channels say I'm a
heretic. I'm dangerous. I'm a son of
Satan. I'm a spiritual bastard. Stay
away from See, this is what my point
exactly. That's my point exactly. But go
ahead, brother.
>> Uh so uh the the uh praying the praying
of the saints. Um
so I I guess I I'll say this. I am not
aware of of of any teaching. So I'll you
know take it with a grain of salt. Um
my my understanding is or at least like
what I can rationalize is that praying
to the saints uh I like your your the
teaching you had where where you said
well you know Protestants like to say
you're praying to the dead. You know I
was I was explaining to this uh this to
her yesterday and I was saying well
that's the wrong language
>> right? It's framed wrong because the
idea is that no one is dead in Christ,
>> right? We're alive. The church is alive.
And so, you're actually not praying to
the dead.
>> And then what Revelations 5 uh brings up
the bowl, the prayers in the bowl and
how the the elders,
>> right? You get what I'm saying?
>> Well, let me show her though. Let me
show her from the scriptures.
>> Okay.
>> So, I wanted her to see with her own
eyes that the Bible says they're not
dead, that they're alive. In fact, I'm
gonna have to go through Hebrews 11. So,
a as you formulate your question, go
ahead. I'm going to bring up the verses
for her. The Bible says if you're in
Christ, when you die, your body is what
dies. Your spirit is alive. And by the
grace of God, you enter his presence by
his grace, fully purged. You're
perfected. You're sin free. You're
wearing a white robe, and you're waiting
to come down with Christ to enter your
body that he'll resurrect. That's
biblical teaching. But formulate your
question as I get the verses for her. Uh
so here here's my question. Um I I I I
guess now I agree that that we can uh
ask for the saints to intercede for us.
>> Yes.
>> When I you know when I was a Protestant
I consider saints to be all humans who
were Christian. That's the way I was
taught. But I understand it might be
different. I'm not I'm not too sure
about that. But regardless my
>> Let me comment on that real quick.
>> Okay. Words do not have one meaning. If
you look at any dictionary, you look at
one word, it gives you a range of
meaning. Right?
>> Okay.
>> The word saint in its basics definition,
the basic definition. If you look at the
word in Hebrew, it's kadosh.
>> Greek, it's agios, right? I'm not trying
to impress you with the biblical
language. I'm just telling you because
holy, you know, you may get a different
idea. Hm. Holy. That means being pure.
If you look at the meaning of the words,
it means to be set apart. to set someone
apart. Set something apart. So if you
ask me what does the word for holy mean
in Hebrew and Greek, it means to
separate something. To separate
something or someone to set something
apart. So a holy one is someone who's
been separated from something. Separated
set aside for God. So in that sense,
anytime someone is baptized in Christ,
God has now separated him from the
world.
So in that basic sense, we're all holy.
We've been separate. There's another
meaning of separation, being separate
from your sin.
Separating from your sin so you don't
sin anymore. Now there are some people
who do a much better job at separating
dist distancing themselves from their
sin and obeying so God so more perfectly
that they stand out and put us to shame.
So a lot of people use the term saint in
that second meaning.
>> Okay.
>> Someone who has so separated himself
from sinning.
>> Okay. and he has so devoted himself to
God,
right, that he just stands out and he's
not like the rest of us. So that's the
second meaning and that's the meaning
that many Catholics and Orthodox go with
when they talk about a saint. But the
basic meaning I just want you to
understand basic meaning
>> it means to be separated
sep set apart from something for
something else. So God separates you
from the world so you don't live like
the world and then sets you apart for
him and for his glory. That's all it
means.
>> Okay. So uh my my thing as far as like
uh interceding uh asking for the for the
saints to intercede for us. I hear a lot
of the these of course I don't know
these people but I hear a lot of the the
other saints. I accept the apostles,
maybe Clement, you know, uh and but then
I hear people like Guadalupe, they just
added uh a young a young programmer boy
that died of
>> Yeah, but they don't just add out of
nothing. There's a strict [snorts]
strict strict criteria for saintthood.
>> Okay.
>> So, the Catholic Church has a strict
criteria. One of the criteria would be
has there been miracles done in the name
of this person? And if you have miracles
done for his sake as a way of God
honoring him especially after he's he's
dead. Now if I die and then someone asks
my intercession and then God answers
that request. So someone says Sam ask
the Lord to do this for me and it
happens.
This becomes a sign that this person is
a saint with the Lord, unless it's
satanic deception. Because why would God
then honor the request of someone
seeking the intercession of someone
who's in hell?
>> It's not easy to be a saint, meaning
that you're now canonized, that you are
glorified, and we know God has given us
enough signs and proofs. You are now
alive, perfected. You have a high rank
in heaven. And God honors you by
honoring those who ask you to pray. It's
not simple. It's not just, you know, oh,
okay. Wait, you know what? I'm bored
today. I'm gonna make him a saint.
>> Yeah. You know, and it it I mean,
remember, I'm looking at this with
Protestant eyes and I'm looking at a lot
of people who've been included as saints
and I go, "Well, what did you know, what
did you actually do?" And then it's for
me, it's like uh I've always been taught
to pray directly to Jesus. We have uh
you know he's the one me
>> even as a Protestant you're not taught
to pray directly to Jesus because when's
the last time you asked your wife to
pray to pray for you
>> yesterday. Yeah.
>> Why don't you go straight to Jesus? Why
did you need to go to her to pray for
you?
>> Right. Right. Right. Right.
>> So that's not true. When Protestants say
we go directly to Jesus. No you don't.
You go to people whom you asked to then
intercede and be a mediator between you
and God.
>> I see what you're saying. I see what
you're saying.
>> It's a pastor. can you pray for my
marriage?
>> Right?
>> The pastor should say, "Hey, hey, uh,
why you need me? Go straight to Jesus."
Uh, pastor, can you pray for me? I'm
sick. Or, pastor, can you pray for my
loved one? He has cancer. Hey, why you
asking me? Go straight to No, that's not
true. No Protestant goes directly to
Jesus all the time. Protestants operate
with the belief understanding God has
called Christians to be intercessors for
one another. And that's why God is
pleased and accepts when you ask your
pastor or your neighbor or your fellow
Christian or your spouse to pray for
you. So this going straight to Jesus,
that's not even true in Protestantism.
>> Can I ask you uh uh something that comes
up? I I don't want again I don't want to
be disrespectful, but I do want
>> No, no, I don't. You know, I I
understand
>> only walk eggshells with your wife, not
me. There's a lot of Catholics and I I'm
learning and at the same time I have a
lot of okay my my father raised me to to
and I I know you've said it before uh
with with the same you know the
revelation the Catholics are the the
people of the revelations the mother
blah blah blah
>> you know what I'm saying
>> yes
>> right okay
>> I don't want to repeat
>> Babylon that
>> exactly so and and and you know the the
main the main arguments our prayer of
the saints and then Mary I don't want to
touch that now
>> it's all right yeah praying Mary you
turn into a goddess but before you go on
what if you raised a Muslim and your
father taught you Christians are pagans
because they worship three gods
>> right
>> we have predispositions to believe you
know in a certain way and I'm trying to
you know unwind
>> yes
>> what what I've been what I've been
taught so uh often uh I hear the the
rebuttal of the the the parable of
Lazarus. Now, I know that that's a
>> what about the rebuttal
>> uh where where the poor man actually I
don't know if it's Lazarus the poor man
outside the rich man.
>> Yeah. Ruth 16:19 to 31. Yes. But what
about
>> a chasm that's been built
>> chasm between hell and heaven and earth.
>> And then the the one in hell says,
"Well, reach." Well, of course.
>> I guess now that I'm saying it, I'm
realizing it. The one in hell says,
"Well, tell my brothers." And then go uh
Abraham says, "Uh, well, he has the
prophets and
>> the law of the prophets." He has the Old
Testament. Exactly.
>> Exactly. So, but the idea of the chasm
that separates
um the realms. What What do you What do
you think?
>> Yeah. I don't understand what's the
connection with intercession of saints.
>> Okay.
>> So, so what's the connection?
Uh I I I've been I've been taught that
there's there's like a a clear I guess
you would say border that blocks
>> the interactions from people who have
entered into heaven, people who have
entered into hell and
>> you're not talking about I'm confused
because the chasm is between those in
the nether world. But aren't they still
communicating with one another?
>> Yes.
>> Aren't they still engaging one another?
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I agree. And if
intercession of the saints was not
appropriate, why is the rich man not
calling out to God? Instead, he's
calling out to Abraham.
>> Oh, look at that. Yeah, look at that.
>> I'm confused. Let me logic.
>> The last place you're going to look for
intercession is in the realm of the
dead. Right.
>> Right. Of course.
>> But the first person he cried out to is
Abraham, not God.
>> Look at that. Yeah.
>> Why is that?
>> I don't know. So I'm that's why I'm
saying so I don't know how this makes
your case because no one thinks
>> No, it's not my case. It's just you know
>> what is it?
>> Not my case. It's just things I've
heard.
>> No, I'm just saying I don't know how it
proves the case of anyone that wants to
argue because no one thinks that if
you're in hell you can be prayed out of
hell. Nobody thinks that. So you're
telling me about a man who for all
intents and purposes seems to have been
in hell. I say seems because I don't
know if that was a purging process that
eventually he'd come out of. I don't
know. But if I take the traditional
understanding, it's hell. Nobody in hell
can be prayed out of hell. That's not
Catholic teaching. That's not Orthodox
teaching. No one in hell can be prayed
out of hell.
So if he's in hell, Abraham's simply
telling him a fact. Sorry. You know, you
did what you did on earth. Now you get
your rewards. Lazarus suffered. Now he's
being rewarded with peace and blessing.
But my question to the person who uses
that say, did you read it? How does this
deny intercession of saints? When the
first person he reaches out to is
Abraham, he doesn't cry out to God.
So why didn't he say, "Oh God, Father
Abraham, please do this for me." That
tells me that the righteous, even in the
realm of the dead, have power and
influence, and God is still using them
to affect those who are in the realm of
the dead.
Wow.
>> What?
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
>> I don't know how that refutes. That
seems like intercession of saints right
there.
>> Yeah.
>> That Abraham is engaging him and telling
him, "Sorry, son. I can't do nothing for
you because you get what you deserve.
You get what you deserve, right? And
besides, because you're there, we're
here. We can't cross over to save you.
That's it. You're going to have to stay
there." But the point that he's crying
out to him and asking him to tell
Lazarus to continue to serve him, that's
an argument that even those in the
afterlife can be invoked and you can
appeal to them and turn to them to do
something for you because I would assume
that he would actually cry out to God in
the realm of the dead,
>> right?
>> He's crying out to Abraham. They'll say,
"Yeah, but he saw Abraham." All right,
but even if he saw Abraham, why cry out
to Abraham even if you see him? You see
him in why not just cry out to God?
And why would Abraham be placed in that
position for him to appeal to Abraham
and cry out to him if not because
Abraham even in the afterlife has power
and influence and is highly exalted by
God that people there still look to him
as the example of what faith is. And
that's why they call him father Abraham
because notice they're calling father
Abraham because he's the father of the
faithful. And what he's saying is you're
not faithful. So I'm not truly your
father
because he's the father of the faithful.
So there's a sense in which you can be a
son of Abraham physically. But Jesus
says that doesn't matter. Being a
physical son of Abraham means nothing.
What really matters is that you are a
spiritual child of Abraham. and how you
become a child of Abraham spiritually,
which was what matters, by believing
like Abraham and behaving like Abraham.
And so what he's telling this man,
though you acknowledge me as your
father, you didn't behave like me and
therefore you're not truly my son.
And that's what Jesus says in John 8.